I noticed that on Instagram stories,...
...I would be watching updates from people that I hadn't spoken to in years.
That's mental bandwidth that's going into something that adds nothing to your life.
If you unfollow them, I bet you won't miss it at all,...
...and that might sound a little bit harsh, but that's honestly how I think this works.
Let me just say that it's okay to let them go.
If they're meant to play a role in your life,...
...they will find a way back into your life.
I promise you.
What I recommend doing is going through the list of people and accounts that you follow,...
...and removing anything that doesn't clearly add value to your life.
In fact, I recommend doing this three times...
...because what will happen is, it'll get easier as you go through.
I found that I got more and more comfortable of this idea of letting people go.
Now, this is very simple actually, but we make it complicated due to social pressure.
Just be mindful,...
...if you feel obligated to follow somebody,...
...or if you're afraid to unfollow someone for fear of their reaction if they found out.
These are not the right reasons to follow somebody, first of all.
And it's important to remember, whose life is this, right?
Yours or theirs?